this is Darwin's historical scientific
method when you're trying to explain an
event in the room up past you want to
draw on your knowledge of
cause-and-effect
and if the effect is a lot of new
digital information we know of a cause
that can do that and it's a mind or an
intelligence here we are on the Sunday
special with special guest Steven Meyer
he's the author of the book Darwin's
doubt an intelligent design advocate
we'll get to all of that in just a
second but first let's talk about your
impending death we're all gonna die at
some point and that's why you should
have life insurance life insurance can
feel like assembling the world's worst
jigsaw puzzle it is confusing it takes
forever and when you're finally done it
doesn't even look cool but if you have a
mortgage or kids or anybody who depends
on your income
it's a puzzle you need to solve policy
genius can help you do it policy genius
is the easy way to get life insurance in
just two minutes you can compare quotes
from top insurers and find the best
policy for you when you apply online the
advisors of policy genius will handle
all the red tape for you they will even
negotiate your rate with the insurance
company no Commission sales agents no
hidden fees just helpful advice and
personalized service policy genius
doesn't just make life insurance easy
they also make it easy to find the right
home insurance auto insurance disability
insurance they're your one-stop-shop for
financial protection so if you find life
insurance puzzling head on over to
policy genius.com do the responsible
thing go check it out in two minutes you
can compare quotes find the right policy
and save up to 40% doing it heck you can
do it from your phone right now just
pause what I'm saying
go get yourself some life insurance of
policy genius policy genius is the easy
way to compare and buy life insurance go
check them out right now it just takes a
couple of minutes and you're doing the
responsible thing policy genius.com go
check them out right now well Stephen
thanks so much for joining the ben
shapiro show absolutely let's start from
the very beginning yeah because people
are gonna ask so you talked a lot about
evolution and science obviously your
books Darwin's doubt and signature in
the cell are both heavily scientific so
what is your scientific background so
folks know well I started in double
majored in physics and geology and then
I worked as a geophysicist for five
years in industry and went from there to
do the program in the philosophy of
science specifically philosophy biology
at Cambridge University where my PhD
dissertation was on the origin of life
problem which was it's a very
interdisciplinary question
how did life first arise from the
presumably the nonliving chemicals so
it's got a biochemistry molecular
biology thermodynamics information
theory it's a it's a question that has
lots of different subjects involved so
it's very interdisciplinary PhD okay so
with all of that said if you go to your
Wikipedia page the first thing that it
says that you're the advocate of a
pseudo pseudo scientific theory called
intelligent design so let's start with a
couple of questions on that first of all
people suggest that you are a
creationist what is the difference
between intelligent design the argument
for intelligent design and creationism
right well creationism holds that it
takes the Bible is the basis of the the
theory so creationism is a as an
interpretation or a deduction from
religious authority whereas intelligent
design is an inference from biological
and physical cosmological evidence so
the one starts from the data of the
natural world the other starts from
Scripture the other the other difference
is that most creationists hold to a view
that the earth is very young it was
created maybe ten thousand years ago or
something I've got ID itself is an age
neutral theory but most of us hold that
the standard ancient dates for the
universe and for life so and planet
Earth so I'm an Old Earth guy so so the
the case that is generally made against
intelligent design is the idea that it's
not a scientific theory so is
intelligent design the idea that there
was somebody you don't actually say God
but but something there was some
intelligent force that moved the
universe that that created life on earth
that was responsible in your book for
the Cambrian explosion how is this a
scientific theory as opposed to just as
maybe Richard Dawkins would say a God of
the gaps argument well one of the things
I did when I first said off to grad
school my story is that I was
encountered this information argument
one of the most extraordinary
discoveries of twentieth-century biology
is that at the foundation of life is
information in a digital form the DNA
molecules stores information in a
four-character digital code and the this
discovery of Watson and Crick in the 50s
has over time created an impasse in both
chemical evolutionary theory which is
which are the theories about the origin
of the first life and there is a by law
evolution as well which are theories
about how you get new forms of life from
pre-existing forms because to build
anything in biology you've got to have
code you've got to have information so I
became fascinated with that question and
the possibility that the the information
that the foundation of life is actually
an indicator of the activity of mind of
an intelligence and but to determine
whether or not that argument could be
formulated scientifically I had to dig
in a little deeper into how scientists
go about reasoning about these origins
questions about events in the remote
past
and oddly one of the people most helpful
to me in that was Charles Darwin himself
because in the 19th century he and his
mentor Charles Lyell the great geologist
developed a method for investigating
historical scientific questions and they
had a principle of reasoning they called
the very cause of principle or the idea
that if you want to explain an event the
remote past you should posit an event a
cause which is known to have the powers
to produce the effect in question and as
I began to think about that I realized
that it was possible to formulate a case
for intelligent design in a strictly
scientific manner and using the method
of Lyell and Darwin because this we
think about the origin of information
the one thing we know is that it always
arises from an intelligent source
whether we're talking about a
hieroglyphic inscription or a paragraph
in a book or information embedded in a
radio signal whenever you find
information especially if it's in a
digital or alphabetic form you trace it
back to its source you'll always come to
a mind not a material process so using
the same scientific method of reasoning
that Darwin used I came to a different
non Darwinian conclusion which was that
there is evidence of intelligent design
not just what the Darwinian is called
apparent design in the history of life
so if our theory is unscientific the
Darwinian theory would be as well but I
think both are scientific I just argued
for one and critique the other so the
philosopher of science Karl Popper has
suggested that science is basically that
which can be falsified so what evidence
would have to arise for the theory of
intelligent design to be falsified you
would have to find an undirected process
that was kid that was capable of
producing
information beyond a threshold that we
have defined mathematically there's a
there's a amount of information that
might arise by chance based on what are
called the probabilistic Univ resources
of the universe but if you get beyond
that from an undirected process that
would falsify our
that only mine can produce that amount
of information there's also other ways
of conceiving of what makes something a
good scientific theory rather than
poppers idea it's been critiqued by
philosophers of science typically a more
more popular view among philosophers of
science is that what scientists are
really doing is they're making
inferences to the best explanation and
that's how I frame the argument in
Darwin's doubt and in signature in the
cell for intelligent design the best
explanation would be one that pauses the
cause which is known to produce the
effect in question and in the best of
cases where there's only one known such
cause and that's the kind of argument I
make for intelligent design that only
intelligence only mind is capable of
generating the amount of information
needed for these big jumps in biological
complexity in the history of life so in
the history of science and the
philosophy of science there's been this
interesting battle between sort of
religious folks who believe that
religion should stay separate from
science and folks who believe that
religion and science are intertwined and
that on the one side you have sort of
the Thomas Aquinas that God and nature
speak in the same language and on the
other side you have the William of Occam
argument that basically God can do
whatever he wants and so what we don't
want is a theory of science that can
disprove God and the flip side of that
is sort of Stephen Jay Gould 's
non-overlapping magisteria argument that
science handles this started religion
handles this stuff and there's no
crossover right so where does
intelligent design lie in in that gap
that's a really great question there's a
bit there's Bakley there's basically
three different approaches to the inter
interface between science and religious
belief one is the idea that two are in
conflict and that was the kind of
dominant view that came out of the late
19th century most historians of science
now reject that is very simplistic
another view is that the the Stephen Jay
Gould view is that science and faith are
in occupy non-overlapping realms of
inquiry that galileo aphorism was
science tells you how the planets go not
how to how to go to heaven you know or
how the heavens go not how to go to
heaven but the theory of intelligent
design I think shows that that's also
simplistic there are many scientific
questions and religious questions that
are completely separate but there are
some there are some there are some
questions that both science and religion
speak to and my view is that when they
speak to the same
in the same way that there is actually
far more agreement than people realize
in fact substantial agreement for
example the origin the universe we now
know had a beginning or the universe had
a beginning and this is one of the first
words of the biblical text that in there
was a beginning so that's a point of
agreement about the same the same issue
did the was is the universe finite or
infinite both science and religion are
now telling us the same thing that that
the universe had a beginning intelligent
design is telling us that life and the
universe were designed and that's
something that you would also find
affirmed in the theistic religious
traditions so that's a point of
agreement about a special question about
in this case about origin the origins of
life so I don't say that science and
religion talk they have many areas of
specialized inquiry they're different
questions that each address but there
are overlapping areas of interest and
increasingly what we found is there's
there is increasing agreement as we
understand the science better and as we
get better more sophisticated biblical
interpretation sometimes as well one of
the the biggest probably the biggest
argument against intelligent design
obviously is made by the new atheists
and the new it's fascinating to watch
the the crossover between neo-darwinian
thinkers and new atheist they basically
are the same they're the same group of
people it seems to me that no surprise
because in Dawkins said you know that
Darwinism makes it possible to be an
intellectually fulfilled atheist or
atheist and also the Darwinian view the
strictly Darwinian view is not just the
idea of evolutionist change over time
but the idea of an undirected unguided
process that produced the appearance but
not the the reality of design so they
see nature essentially as being a self
creating entity that can produce all the
wonders of an intricacies of living
organisms without any guiding hand
whatsoever and so that that lends itself
to a strictly materialistic or atheistic
worldview well people have suggested
that intelligent design advocates are
anti evolution that they they don't
believe in the theory of evolution so
what does the theory of evolution say to
start and then what in it is is in
argument too far that's that's a great
question this the term evolution is a
term that has multiple meanings so if
you want to avoid the fallacy of
equivocation it's really good to define
terms right from the beginning so
meaning has changed over time obviously
and that that can mean a couple
different things itself it can refer to
the small-scale variation that we see
with things like the Galapagos finches
where their beaks get a little bigger a
little smaller in response to varying
weather conditions it can also refer to
the fact that life on the planet today
is different than it was in the period
of the Jurassic when you had the
dinosaurs roaming the earth or in the
Cambrian when you had trilobite s--
we've had change in the representation
of life forms over time in the fossil
record nobody doubts either of those
meanings of evolution second big meaning
of evolution is the idea that all forms
of life are connected by common ancestry
back to a single ancestral form a single
one celled organism so Darwin
represented that idea with his concept
of the Tree of Life that's an idea of
evolution that's consistent with the
idea of intelligent design those many
intelligent design proponents and others
other scientists including evolutionary
biologists are getting increasingly
skeptical about it because there's so
much evidence of discontinuity in the
fossil record and discontinuity in the
in the study of genomics but we have
things like orphan genes which are big
classes of genes that are unique to
certain taxa and don't show any
similarity to other genes anywhere else
in the in the in the in the genomic
databases so you have this sense of you
know genetic information popping into
existence in different classes of
organisms discontinuity third meaning of
evolution is the one though that's
really that's this really contentious
and that's the idea that that natural
selection and random mutation are
sufficient to produce all the new forms
of life and the appearance of design
that living forms manifests so it's an
unguided process that produces the
appearance but not the reality of design
and that's that's the meaning of
evolution that the theory of intelligent
design is challenging there's some
intelligent design proponents may be
skeptical about common descent others
are not but it's that third meaning that
unites us and and and and it's what the
theory of intelligent design is about
we're challenging the idea that purely
undirected processes can produce the
complexity or the information necessary
to build the complexity of living
organisms so you make a couple of
arguments in your two books Darwin's
doubt as well as signature in the cell
one is a DNA related argument one is a
fossil record related argument but they
go back as you say
to that theory of evolution that
suggests that natural selection and
genetic mutation are enough alone to to
lead to the way that life has developed
over time wondering if you can start by
spelling out where is the discontinuity
with regard to the establishment of of
life well the first big discontinuity is
the origin of life itself which is what
my first book signature in the cell
addressed and many people don't realize
that Darwin himself never addressed the
question of the origin of the first life
he speculated about it in a letter to a
friend but he didn't this was not
something he addressed in the Origin of
Species he presupposed the existence of
the first living cell and there's a
major discontinuity between chemical
processes that we observe and what we
see in actual living organisms and and
it's a complexity gap that's absolutely
extraordinary but tiny miniature
machines we have not only the DNA with a
digital code in it but a complex
information processing system and even
the even the simplest living cells on
earth so that's a big discontinuity
there are then there is a series of
discontinuities in the fossil record as
we find greater and greater complexity
arising over time one of the big ones
that I talked about in Darwin's doubt
was one that Darwin that bothered Darwin
a great deal which was what we now call
the Cambrian explosion which was the
which is and the origin of the first
major groups of animals in the fossil
record there attested in the middle
Cambrian in particular and many groups
of animals exemplifying completely new
body plans arise a very narrow window of
geologic time very abruptly without
discernible connection to ancestral
precursors in the lower Precambrian
strata and that's one of the big
discontinuities in the history of life
there are many others I've written an
article with a german paleontologist
gunther Beckley about 17 such major
discontinuities the mammalian radiation
the origin of flowering plants the first
winged insects the dopplers dinosaurs
most of the major groups of living forms
on earth arise discontinuously so that's
a big deal the even bigger question
though that I addressed in the book is
apart from that discontinuity which is a
puzzle for Darwinism how would you build
those organisms what process could
account for the origin of all that new
form especially now that we know
you need information the information in
DNA and from other sources to build
complex new forms of life let's talk
about information theory so for folks
who don't whoever in your books don't
know anything about information theory
why does information theory suggest that
there must be some sort of designer
obviously people like Dawkins who
suggest that that evolution is the
universal acid that they say that these
things can arise by themselves they
would also make the suggestion that the
information in DNA is not necessarily
directed that it only seems directed to
us cuz we're here to actually look at
the direction in which it moves it could
theoretically be random what does
information theory have to say well it's
actually helpful first to go back to the
molecular biological revolution of the
1950s Watson and Crick discover in 1953
they elucidate rather the structure of
the DNA molecule they discovers got this
beautiful helix structure they got there
there's these four chemical subunits
that run along the interior of the helix
called bases or nucleotides in 1957 1958
Crick who was interestingly a code
breaker in World War two posits what's
known as the sequence hypothesis which
is just a breakthrough moment in the
history of biology where he realizes
that the nucleotide base is on the
inside of the double helix are
functioning like alphabetic characters
in a written language or what we now
think of as like the zeros and ones in a
section of software code which is to say
it's not the physical or chemical
properties of those bases that is
important to their function but rather
it's their sequential arrangement in a
in accord with an independent code which
was later elucidated and we now call the
genetic code so what we have is a true
information bearing system that is that
is expressing information as it happens
for building the proteins and protein
machines that cells need to stay alive
so in Seattle where I live we've got
great information companies we got
Microsoft which writes code we've got
Boeing and other manufacturing companies
that use code and there's a process
called computer assisted design and
manufacturing CAD CAM where an engineer
might write some code code go down a
wire be converted into another machine
language that could be read by a
manufacturing apparatus and that
information will then direct the
construction of a mechanical system if
you're
might put rivets exactly on the right
place on the on the airplane wing so
you've got in from and the same thing
that's going on inside the cell that
you've got information directing the
construction of proteins and protein
machines that are absolutely necessary
for for survivability so the big
question is where does that information
come from and also what kind of
information is it and that's where the
information theory comes in in the late
40s there was a scientist named Claude
Shannon who developed a mathematical
theory of information but his theory
only captured his theory of information
had to do with the reduction of
uncertainty which he showed was
inversely related to improper to
probability more improbable an
arrangement of characters the more
Shannon information that was carried but
his notion of information didn't capture
the the notion of meaning or
communication function so you could have
a series of characters that were
basically gibberish but because they
were a periodic and random you couldn't
really tell whether they were meaningful
or not but they had a big information
measure so Shannon didn't capture the
difference between functional or
meaningful information and just an
improbable arrangement of characters so
it's actually not information theory but
as information theory plus a qualitative
judgment about what the sequence is
doing that allows us to recognize the
kind of information that we're familiar
with in our own parlance but the
dictionary talks about variable
sequences of characters for conveying a
meaning or a function and that's what we
have in DNA and Francis Crick was very
clear on that from the beginning he said
it's not mere Shannon information it's
information that's functional and that's
the kind of information that in our
experience always indicates the prior
activity of an intelligence if it's just
a random arrangement might be undirected
processes but if it's if it's very
specific and complex and its operating
in in accord with a symbol convention
then you've got information that is the
product of mind and so this is this is
where we get into the theories of
probability because the question becomes
could there have been such a strand of
DNA that comes about by chance because
the theory obviously as you mentioned of
evolution suggests that its mutations
now in the DNA that create all of the
change
and human life over time so let's get
the origin of life problems and then and
then and then we'll and then we'll but
but when it comes to the information
string in the DNA the contention is
basically that given enough time you run
the experiments enough times and
eventually you will end up with an
evolution that and combined with natural
selection it preserves the mutations
that are good and you will end up with a
something that looks designed even
though it is not designed that mutation
over time being preserved by natural
selection is enough why doesn't that
work it's there's a mathematical problem
and it's a profound one my colleague
David Berlinski calls it the
combinatorial problem or the problem of
combinatorial inflation
maybe simple analogy way to get into it
we know from our experience with
software code writing and and using it
that the last thing you want in a
section of functional software code is a
random series of random changes to those
zeros and ones if that happens you're
going to degrade the information that's
in that code long before you'll ever
generate a new software program or
operating system and Richard Dawkins and
many many others biologists have
acknowledged that what we have in DNA is
akin to machine code or as Leroy hood
puts a digital code it's that it's
functioning in exactly the same way so
what we've learned from software writing
and using is highly relevant to
understanding whether or not the
mutation selection mechanism would
actually generate could generate
conceivably or realistically new
information and there's a there's
there's a reason that changing software
at random invariably degrades the
information before you get anything
useful and new and that is because
there's so many more ways to go wrong in
any in any system of digital or
typographic or alphabetic communication
there are there are vastly more ways of
arranging the characters in question
that will generate gibberish then there
are ways of arranging those same
characters that will generate something
functional so if you start randomly
changing things you're overwhelmingly
more likely to find a gibberish sequence
than a functional one and as we've
actually tried to quantify that how much
more likely the the quantitative odds
are prohibitive there's a scientists who
work for 14 years at at Cambridge
University and Douglas
does PhD at Caltech went on to do a
molecular long-term molecular biology
research postdoc at Cambridge to try to
quantify this question how rare or
common are the functional sequences that
would make a new protein or a new new
gene capable of making a new protein how
how rare are the functional ones in
comparison to the non functional ones
and for a relatively short protein about
150 amino acids long he determined that
the ratio of functional to
non-functional sequences was about 1
over 10 to the 77th power now to put
that in context there are only 10 to the
sixty-fifth atoms in the Milky Way
galaxy so what that means is that a
random search for a new functional
sequence is going to be like looking for
one marked atom among 10 trillion or
sorry yeah at what 1 trillion galaxies
of the size the Milky Way so and what it
turns out that even 4 billion years of
life's history is not enough time to to
solve a search problem of that magnitude
and I go into all the math of this in
the book and and it's it's pretty
straightforward there's only 10 to the
40th organisms in history the planet not
enough replication events to search a
space 10 to the 77 big so you're looking
at even in the whole if you take the
whole history of life on the planet into
account you're only gonna be able to
search a tiny tiny fraction of the total
relative relevant sequences so you got a
really big haystack really small number
of needles and very little time to look
for them the bottom line is it's
overwhelmingly and more probable that
such a search will fail than succeed in
the known time of life on planet Earth
which means that the mechanism is more
likely the hypothesis that the mechanism
produced new information is more likely
to be false and true and so the result
of this is as you say that it's more
likely that it's that it's designed than
that it was randomly done in terms of
DNA and that's reflected in in the
fossil record in the extent to the
extent that there have - there's sort of
these jumps in the fossil record there's
what you talked about in Darwin's doubt
is that it's not a continuous process of
a mutation upon mutation building one on
the other just randomly it becomes a big
engineering problem because it's not
just that there's gaps in the fossil
record
to ask well how would the evolutionary
process produce all the new information
necessary to build these completely new
body plans new cell types new anatomical
structures and we know it would take a
lot of new information and so then
you've got to look well is there enough
time to do that do you have enough
trials through this mechanism and the
answer is just overwhelmingly no it's
not plausible at all mathematically and
on the flip side we do know however of a
cause that is sufficient to produce new
information this is why it's not a god
of the gaps or an argument from
ignorance is where we're drawing and
this is Darwin's historical scientific
method when you're trying to explain an
event in the room up past you want to
draw on your knowledge of
cause-and-effect
what kind of cause is out there that
we've observed that is capable of
producing the effect in question and if
the effect is a lot of new digital
information we know of a cause that can
do that and it's a mind or an
intelligence and it happens that's
that's the only known cause that can
produce lots of new information and it's
certainly much more plausible than the
Darwinian idea of a random search and we
show why mathematically it's much more
plausible now one of the theories about
the the idea that that randomness is
still in the system is Stephen Jay Gould
idea of punctuated equilibrium then that
essentially small groups of animals kind
of went away from the big group they
they did all their changes and then they
reintegrated why doesn't that work the I
did that the the jumps in the fossil
record are results of small groups
breaking away in a certain level of
group selection yeah
Gould model was a terrific advance as
far as its accuracy in describing the
fossil record because he described these
big punctuation Zoar big jumps and then
the long-term stasis that would occur
lack of directional evolutionary change
that's what we see in the fossil record
very non Darwinian the problem was he
didn't really have a mechanism that
could accomplish the the that could
produce the amount of change that we're
seeing I discussed it as a whole chap I
do a whole chapter on this in Darwin's
doubt but the mechanism he proposed was
called species selection a lot of other
evolutionary biologists including
Richard Dawkins were very critical of
the mechanism and in a way rightly so
because what it came down to in the end
was that species selection itself
depended on the natural selection random
mutation mechanism and that mechanism
requires lots of time to get the job
done and it turns
four billion years isn't enough but
certainly the the abrupt jumps that
Gould was talking about we're not
allowing the mechanism enough time to
work so you had this this kind of irony
in evolutionary biology and then 80s and
90s in particular Gold's model pretty
much was dismissed by the early 2000s
but you had Gould model was viewed as a
good one for describing the fossil
record accurately but it didn't have a
mechanism the Darwinian 's had a
mechanism but it was inconsistent with
the fossil record and also then as we've
later critique the mechanism was also
lacks the creative power to generate the
information necessary to build big new
you know major innovations in the
history of life so from a design
perspective what exactly is the theory
of how one species would become another
suddenly is that there's a bunch of dead
DNA that is suddenly activated or is it
that you know write something injects
new information into the system how
exactly would that work well mechanism
the the question of species raises this
whole question of envelopes of
variability we see evidence of design at
the the low sigh of the design are when
you get the major innovations occurring
in the history of life but the
information that is present in a major
group of organisms might be sufficient
to allow a lot of variation within
within an envelope so that's why there
is evolution we think there is there's
clearly evolution that takes place the
question is how how much information was
present and how how wide the envelopes
of variability are that are generated by
that information so there's a terrific
evolutionary biologist and cell biology
biologists at the University of Chicago
also named Shapiro James Shapiro who's
got a new theory of evolution he calls
natural genetic engineering and he
notices that and has documented that
that many of the mutations that we
actually see at work are not random at
all they're they're an expression of
what he calls pre-programmed adaptive
capacity where there's a an external
trigger or stress put on an organism and
that triggers the production of certain
proteins that for which the organism had
the capability of building all along
because it had the genetic information
there and so a lot of the evolution we
see is actually pre programmed adaptive
capacity
which is really an exciting biological
phenomenon that the Darwinian --hz
haven't really taken full account of but
it does raise the question of the origin
of that adaptive capacity where the
pre-programming come from so intelligent
design says the the inputs of
information from outside the system from
an intelligence are located in that
pre-programmed adaptive capacity but it
the theory also acknowledges that there
is evolution possible going downstream
as a result of that pre-existing
information all right so let's talk
about the origin of life problem the the
question being how did organic life
arise from non-organic material there
are some experiments that were done in
the early 20th century in which under
certain conditions it looked as though
maybe organic material could be created
from non-organic material but there
really as you pointed out has not been a
great explanation of how non-organic
material could create an information
system like DNS so yeah the famous
experiments still in a lot of the
biology textbooks is the miller-urey
experiment of 1950 to 1953 they sparked
a a chamber that had gases known as
reducing gases that then spontaneously
produced a few of the 20 protein forming
amino acids two or three problem is that
amino acids do not a protein make and
proteins by themselves do not make life
so they were really quite a long ways
away from demonstrating anything like a
spontaneous chemical origin of life it's
ironic that that experiment was
performed in the same year as Watson and
Crick's discovery of the structure of
the DNA molecule and the subsequent
elucidation the information bearing
properties of the molecule because in
what's called chemical evolutionary
theory by the 1960s and certainly by the
early 1980s the field reached a state of
impasse precisely because the biologists
and the and the biochemists realized
that to build an actual living cell
you've got to have information-rich
molecules you can't just have the
components you can't just have the
letters you've got to have the sentences
and and so there were a number of
problems with the miller-urey experiment
one was they presuppose conditions on
the early Earth and in the early Earth's
atmosphere that didn't actually match
the conditions on the early earth we
didn't have an early a reducing
atmosphere we had a slightly oxidizing
or neutral atmosphere here
run those experiments you don't get
amino acids forming spontaneously but
the bigger problem was how he arranged
the amino acids in in the very specific
ways that are required to form a
three-dimensional structure called a
protein fold and that problem hasn't
been solved apart from watching DNA do
it inside living cells so to build
proteins what we know is you need
information stored in the DNA molecule
and so as as the molecular biological
Revolution unfolded in this in the 50s
60s 70s people the scientists working on
the origin of life realized the problem
was much harder than they realized
because they didn't just need to account
for certain kinds of building blocks of
life they needed to account for the
information that would organize the
building blocks into DNA molecules into
protein molecules and into the complex
information processing systems they
characterized even the simplest living
cells so one of the theories that has
been posited to sort of solve this
problem is the so called RNA world
thesis can you talk about yeah so one of
the reasons that origin of like problem
is so hard for evolutionary biologists
is you can't invoke natural selection
reasonably because natural selection
only it that's depends on
self-replication differential survival
of lots of offspring okay but that only
happens differential organisms only
divide and reproduce on the basis of
things that are happening at a molecular
level that involve information-rich DNA
and proteins so if you're trying to
explain the origin of information-rich
DNA and proteins you can't invoke
prebiotic natural selection it's a
contradiction in terms as one of the
great evolutionary biologists of Jansky
said so that made the origin of life
problem even harder than the problems
we've been talking about previously as
far as explaining the origin of the
information for new forms of life but
one theory that attempted to get around
that is called the RNA world and it was
it was based on the observation that
some RNA molecules can generate it can
form perform two functions at once they
can perform the function of information
storage like DNA but they can also
catalyze certain reactions like proteins
proteins catalyze it much faster rates
than would otherwise occur really
crucial biochemical reactions that are
crucial in metabolism
so if RNA could do both the thought was
then maybe life started with an RNA
molecule that could copy itself that
could get natural selection going at a
molecular level before you had life
problem is turned out again to be an
information problem so we've done
experiments on RNA it's turned out that
we've people have they call them
ribozyme engineering experiments and the
that the name is apt because it is a lot
of intelligent designs a lot of
engineering but people have tried to
engineer RNA molecules by arranging the
sequence of bases RNA like DNA has these
these bases that carry information and
they've arranged the bases very
specifically just tried to build RNA
molecules that would copy themselves to
get a self-replicating system going
which would get natural selection going
problem is number one we have been able
to design some RNA molecules that will
copy about 10% of themselves but only if
the bases are very specifically arranged
which means that to get a
self-replicating system going you got to
have information and where is the
information coming from it's coming from
the intelligent biochemist who's doing
the ribozyme engineering so what's
actually being simulated in these
simulations is the need we argue for
intelligent design the RNA world doesn't
eliminate or it doesn't refute the the
intelligent design argument based on
information it actually demonstrates or
illustrates the need for intelligent
design and so I don't think it really
solves the problem unless RNA world
people are saying well that's where the
intelligent designer input the
information in the first place
okay so it seems like that the biggest
blow back that you've gotten obviously
in terms of intelligent design is the
term intelligent design because seems
like most of the critiques that you've
made of neo-darwinism are fairly well
accepted is that accurate increasingly
so in 2016 a number of us went attended
a conference at the Royal Society of
London in obviously London and it was a
group of leading evolutionary biologists
called the meeting to address new trends
in evolutionary biology they called it
was innocuous way of saying
neo-darwinism is dead and we need a new
theory first talk of the conference was
by a leading Austrian evolutionary
biologist named GERD Muller who
enumerated five what he called
explanatory deficits of neo-darwinism
elsewhere he's written that
neo-darwinism
has no theory of the generative by which
he means it explains the small scale
variations very well like the Galapagos
finches but it doesn't explain the
origin of major innovations in the
history of life and so many evolutionary
biologists are now there's an aphorism
it's afoot it's a mutation and selection
explained the survival but not the
arrival of the fitness the problem is
the the main mechanism of evolutionary
change doesn't seem to have significant
creative power and that's the problem I
think increasingly being recognized and
as a result of that many people within
evolutionary biology are looking for new
mechanisms calling for the formulation
of a new theory and that's kind of
that's kind of striking it's an
astounding admission when you think
about how the theory is presented
through the textbooks through with
science popularizers the New Atheists
the the public spokesman for science the
National Center for Science Education or
the the National Academy of Sciences
when they talk about evolution it's a
fact Richard Dawkins has said that if
you if you find someone who questions it
they're either stupid wicked or insane
but the reality on the ground or rather
in the peer-reviewed literature within
evolutionary biology is very different
there's a recognition that the
fundamental problems haven't been solved
and one of which is muler knowledge the
problem of the origin of biological form
when I saw that it was it's an it's in a
table and in in a book that he's written
with another evolutionary biologist is a
list of unsolved problems one of which
they list the origin of biological form
I was stunned this 2003 MIT press that
was the very problem that Darwin was
supposed to have solved in 1859 and it's
now an open question but with that said
it seems like for a lot of folks like
Dawkins it's not about the God of the
gaps about the Darwinism of the gaps the
idea that eventually we're gonna figure
out that Darwinism still holds in these
circumstances where it appears not to
hold it is that accurate or does you
have a theory for how to think well
there's a yeah there's a very good
explanation for that in the sociology
and philosophy of science the assumption
is we have to have a materialistic
explanation we can't allow creative
intelligence or agency or mind
- we can't posit that as part of the
explanation for how life got here and
there's a rule that many scientists take
as normative is called methodological
naturalism and it says
you're gonna be a scientist you have to
explain everything by reference to
purely undirected material processes and
if you deviate from that in any way
you're not being scientific that's why I
got called a pseudo scientist on the the
Wikipedia webpage was a little bit of an
upgrade because previously they had me
down as a theologian and I've no no
training in theology but in any case
this methodological rule is actually
only as recent as the late 19th century
in science the founders of modern
science Newton Boyle Keppler they didn't
adhere to this at all they saw design in
science well in the in the natural world
and they wrote about it in their science
in their in their science treatise for
example in the general Scullion to the
print Kippy the Newton's great work on
gravitation he's got a terrific argument
for design based on the fine-tuning of
the planetary orbits so design arguments
were part of science from its foundation
but they be they became their boat in in
the late 19th century after the the
Origin of Species and there's a very
curious thing about this rule of
methodological naturalism if you're if
you're investigating an origin question
or a causal origins question it's a rule
that actually limits the intellectual
freedom of the scientist there's a lot
of a lot of areas of science where
methodological naturalism is innocuous
but if you're asking the question what
caused life or the information necessary
to produce life to arise and you
recognize it could be an undirected
material process or it might have been
in mind but then you decide in advance
that you're not going to consider any
evidence of mind of course you're only
going to get materialistic explanations
but the explanations may not be adequate
um and imagine you go into the the
British Museum you look at the Rosetta
Stone you see all those inscriptions in
three different languages and you say
well I'd like to say it was a scribe but
since I adhere to methodological
naturalism I've got to say it was wind
and erosion or something like that the
the rule actually limits scientists from
following the evidence where it most
naturally leads information based on our
knowledge of cause and effect is a
strong indicator of the activity of
intelligence and yet we can't say that
or consider that if we accept
methodological naturalism and that's
what's going on that's why the the
dialectic kind of goes in circles work
you get a new evolutionary model every
few years and then they circle back to
the one that was rejected you know 20 20
years ago and start the cycle
over again because we're really looking
in the wrong place we're barking up the
wrong tree I mean it does raise the
question if you're a methodological
naturalist and all you believe is that
undirected processes are responsible for
everything why you believe in such a
thing as objective truth for example
because we're the reliability of the
human mind as we were discussing before
the interview right I mean if the idea
is that the human mind is capable of
grasping the world around it and there
is such a thing as objective truth that
we can grasp then that would suggest
that our mind reflects the universe in
some deep profound way as opposed to the
sort of evolutionary biology belief
which is that we are just adaptable
balls of mates and so whatever we think
about the universe maybe it's helpful in
terms of our adaptation but it's not
necessarily true very well but this was
the the very thing that bothered Thomas
Nagel the great philosopher of science
from NYU Nagel got himself in a bit of
trouble he wrote a favorable review of
signature in the cell in The Times
Literary Supplement
and then there was a huge blowback
including from a lot of other fellow
atheist niggles an atheist but Nagel
accepted that the the critical arguments
in signature in the cell and began to
get more critical of Darwinism as well
not just chemical evolutionary theory
but biological evolutionary theory and
in 2012 he doubled down by publishing
his own book with oxford press called
mind and cosmos how the neo-darwinian
materialist view of reality is almost
certainly false was a subtitle and his
problem was the one that you just
articulated that clearly we live in a
universe in which mind is a reality and
if neo-darwinism can't account for that
then it's missing something really big
so it's it's an inadequate explanation
for something we observe all the time
which is the activity of Minds I see it
in our conversation I know I have a mind
by my own introspective experience this
is a part of reality too and if the if
evolution can't account for that and if
we exclude mind as an explanatory
principle we're gonna have an
impoverished understanding of the world
around us and so I think this is a very
very important aspect of the debate as
well is recognizing that mind is a
reality well this actually is one of the
fascinating sort of theories that the
dawkins puts forth is essentially the
mind is a spandrel that mind is is just
something that we feel like we have but
it actually does not exist in the first
place which does raise the question as
to why
he does what he does for a living I mean
if you're in the business of explanation
why bother operating along the spandrels
it's extremely self-defeating you're
absolutely right but it's interesting
that the Neo Darwinists say that design
in life is an illusion
we have apparent design but not real
design its first line from the blind
watchmaker page one biology is the study
of complicated things that give the
appearance of having the design for
purpose but in the at the end of the day
Dawkins also has to say that mind itself
purpose of intelligence is also an
illusion that's an impoverished
worldview we all know better than that
well it does raise questions I mean far
beyond that for civilization as well
since we all have to live together in
rat and and reason together I've had
this exact argument with Sam Harris who
friend who says he believes an objective
truth and reason and I keep saying to
him while we're wandering balls of meat
with no purpose in the universe Oh what
is this reason you're talking about or a
bunch of firing neurons over which we
have no control yeah two points on that
I think you've addressed them both I
think you're addressing with the point
you just made in your new book but our
whole legal system is based on notions
of moral responsibility culpability
before the law that presupposes our
ability to choose as free agents that
were not completely determined by
undirected you know firings and our
synapse you know it was not just nature
or nurture there's there's there's human
free will and moral responsibility our
whole legal system is based on that idea
and secondly there's the there's we have
this epidemic of teen suicide in our
country and I heard something you did on
your show a little while ago and I had a
very similar experience of kind of
existential anxiety as a young person it
was a fairly middle-class upbringing I
had no great deprivation but I had this
recurring question what's gonna matter
in a hundred years what is what will any
human achievement ever matter and this
question of the purpose of human
existence I think is gnawing at a lot of
people in our culture especially young
people because only agents only personal
agents can confer meaning on something
nothing can mean something to Iraq or to
an atom and we find meaning in
relationship to other persons and if at
the end of the day we're just gonna have
this heat death of the universe and
there's no mind behind the universe no
personal agency behind the universe
there's no possibility of ultimate
meaning and a lot of people sense that
it's very deeply true
and we're really not answering that
question for a lot of young people I
think one of the the philosophical
implications of intelligent design which
doesn't attempt to prove the existence
of God but it does imply that personal
agency is fundamental to the cosmos and
it it opens up the possibility that
there there could be a good answer to
that question of meaning and purpose
that I think snowing in a lot of people
so let's talk about how intelligent
design should be taught and so as we've
mentioned a lot of scientists basically
accept the the generalized critiques of
neo-darwinism that you've expressed in
your books is there a reason why we
don't just say we don't know in other
words why don't we try and just teach it
this way here's the theory of
neo-darwinism here all the flaws in the
theory of neo-darwinism it would be very
difficult for folks to try and kick that
out of school since you're not
mentioning god right and you're not
mentioning any intelligent designer at
all why not
teacher that way then you're firmly
within even the skeptics view of what
science ought to be that happens to be
our science education policy at the
Discovery Institute we propose that
students are allowed to teach to learn
about the strengths and the weaknesses
of different scientific theories
including Darwinian evolution but there
are many a lot of a lot of a lot of
people have a stereotyped view of
science which is really inaccurate it's
the you know the men in white coats and
the it's just about the facts and
there's no role for interpretation or
debate or argument but science advances
there's a wonderful Italian philosopher
of science named marchello pero who says
that science advances as scientists
argue about how to interpret the
evidence and what we've done is present
a stereotyped view of science to
students where we just tell them the
answer and say that well here are the
facts and and in the theory that
explains it and it's all a fait accompli
a much better way to learn science is to
learn about the arguments that are
ongoing now we have this complication in
the United States with our church-state
jurisprudence and we at discovery think
that at this point at least it's sort of
it's just borrowing trouble to try to
buck that but what we certainly can do
without any problem with the the
constitutional a constitutional
precedent is to allow students to learn
the the strengths of Darwinian theory
and also the scientific weaknesses as we
find them increasingly in the
peer-reviewed literature in biology and
evolutionary biology
I testified before the Texas State Board
of Education several years ago for in
favor of a proposal to do exactly what
I'm describing and to teach the
strengths and weaknesses I submitted
into evidence about a hundred peer
reviewed papers of leading people in
evolutionary biology pointing out
serious weaknesses in the theory
especially around this problem of the
lack of creative power of the mutation
selection mechanism at that same hearing
well prior to my opposite number at the
National Center for science education at
Darwin only science education Lobby said
to the the the press the Dallas Morning
News you can't apply the strengths and
weakness's standard to evolutionary
theory because the theory of evolution
has no weaknesses well that's that's
actually laughable when you get into the
scientific literature and student ah
just as a matter of scientific literacy
to know about the problems with the
theory that the scientists themselves
are talking about so that's what we've
been advocating so let's talk for a
second about the intelligent designer so
when you say intelligent design
everybody goes to ok that's God but your
theory doesn't actually suggest that
it's necessarily God it just says there
has to be some form of mind or
intelligence that was responsible for
this how do you connect the intelligent
design theory to God or is it connected
to got it all right thanks for asking
it's a great question and the the first
thing is to understand why from the
biological evidence we make an inference
to a mind of some kind when we're
reasoning about the history of life
we're using this Darwinian principle of
the very cause of principle or using our
knowledge of cause and effect what do we
know from cause and effect well we know
from cause and effect that it takes a
mind with self conscious awareness to
create or generate information in a
digital form and so we can infer at leat
that there was a mind that at least had
the kind of capabilities of which we are
familiar we because of our own
introspective experience of having minds
now when we're talking about the
biological evidence the designing
intelligence responsible might be an
imminent intelligence within the cosmos
or it could be a transcendent
intelligence that has the attributes
that Jews and Christians ascribe to the
deity both our logical possibilities so
I've always said when in my books on the
evidence of design and biology that the
theory of intelligent design isn't an
argument for the for God's existence but
it may have theistic implications it's
theistic friendly now I happen to be
writing another book
is extending the design argument into
the realm of cosmology and the
foundations of physics where we find at
the foundation of physical law these
incredibly finely tuned parameters it's
called the anthropic fine-tuning and the
physicist since the 50s and 60s have
been discovering dozens of these fine
tuning parameters both in the way the
universe was set up at the beginning and
the configuration of mass energy and in
the the the relative strengths of the
different forces of physics and a number
of other parameters like the expansion
rate of the universe and the speed of
light and things like this and it turns
out we live in what they call a
Goldilocks universe that the forces are
not too strong not too weak the
expansion rate not too fast not too slow
the arrangement of the the mass energy
just right at the beginning we live in a
just right universe that has made life
possible now that I argue and many
physicists have argued is also evidence
of design but that evidence of design is
located at the very beginning of the
universe and neither the beginning of
the universe which we now know of as a
result of our Big Bang Theory nor the
fine-tuning can be accounted for by an
agent within the cosmos clearly no space
alien or imminent intelligence could be
responsible for the laws of physics and
the fine-tuning of all those laws that
make it's very life possible
nor could such an agent be responsible
for the origin of the universe itself so
I think when you bring that other
evidence into the picture that you I
think you can make a very strong
theistic design argument and in my next
book which is gonna be called the return
of the god hypothesis i look at how a
theism as opposed to other competing
metaphysical hypotheses such as
pantheism or materialism or deism best
explains that ensemble of evidence from
biology physics and cosmology so I do
think you can make a theistic argument
not a proof for God's existence but
again an inference to the best
explanation of this ensemble of evidence
we have about biological and
cosmological origins now is there an
easy way out for folks when it comes to
the fine-tuning argument or to the
information argument by simply saying
that there is no such actual distinction
between meaningful information and
Chanin information there's no such
distinction between fine-tuning and non
fine-tuning except that we're here to
see it in other words if the only thing
that distinguishes an infirm
rich segments of text from a non
information rich segment of text is the
fact that we speak English so if there's
a bunch of letters and we can read them
than we think that they're meaningful if
there's a bunch of letters we can't read
them we think that they're not
meaningful so in other words are we
reverse projecting mind onto a universe
simply because we're here to well no
because we do objectively recognize
meaning and function there is a
possibility of false false negative
false negative judgments we might see a
string of characters and not know the
symbol convention and therefore conclude
that that string is just random or
complex but without being specified but
when we make a qualitative judgment of
specificity of arrangement when we see
that the arrangement of characters is
necessary to perform an independently
observable function that's a kind of
information that is real and is
something that we know is only
associated with a causal activity of
intelligent agents so no biologist
really when you get down to it wants to
say well the sequence of characters in
the DNA you know the a c's and g's in
the in the DNA molecule the arrangement
doesn't matter for building proteins
because all we have to do is change the
arrangement and see that the the protein
unfolds and doesn't and doesn't catalyze
a reaction there's a real objective way
of recognizing function in biology just
as there is in in in human language so I
think the this qualitative in
information in the information Sciences
there's a distinction between specified
or functional information on the one
hand and mere complexity or randomness
or Shannon information on the other and
that's a real distinction and it under
writes the whole case for intelligent
design you're right okay so so the the
countervailing case for a lot of this
stuff is the theory of multiple universe
I was so I was hoping you would ask
about that I mean people essentially
saying that that we are a bubble
universe that is on a bunch of other
bubbles you know there are an infinite
number of universes so all of the
probabilistic arguments that you make in
favor of the chain of life in the
creation of life none of this matters in
the end because there are a bajillion
universes right we just happen to be
exactly and they call it the observer
selection effect we think we're special
because all the conditions that are
necessary for our existence are so
incredibly improbable but in fact some
universe somewhere had to arise that
produced organisms such as ourselves
conscious aware a conscious and Intel
agents indeed but there's a problem with
this whole this whole approach many
problems in fact and you might imagine
in this new book that I'm doing I'm
writing quite a lot about the multiverse
and critique of it but let me give you
the most important problem and that is
the multiverse itself requires a prior
fine-tuning the multiverse hypothesis
presupposes a prior fine-tuning here's
the problem if you have all these
different universes out there AGGA
billion of them
if the universes aren't in some way
connected then what happens in one
universe has no material effect on
events in another universe so the the
fact that there may be a gabelli on
other universes out there if they're
disconnected doesn't change anything in
our universe including the probabilities
of our being here so to solve that
problem and in recognition of that
problem proponents of the multiverse
have proposed a common cause for all the
universes so that they can so they can
portray the multiverse all these
different universes as the results of
something like a big cosmic lottery
where there's some mechanism that's
churning out universes where eventually
one of them would have to have the right
combination of factors to make life
possible
now the problem though is that in all
the universe generating mechanisms that
have been proposed there is prior
fine-tuning there's something called
inflationary cosmology and another and
there's something called this string
theoretic landscape so there's a string
theory version of the multiverse and
there's an inflationary cosmology
version and in both cases there has to
be exquisite fine-tuning for the
universe generating mechanism to
actually produce multiple universes so
the universe the the problem of the
origin of the fine-tuning has just been
pushed back one generation one of my
philosopher physics colleagues Robin
Collins uses an illustration like this
he says so imagine you have some chef
presents a beautiful loaf of bread to
you and you say oh chef I'd like to
compliment your skill as a chef but I
know you didn't actually design the
recipe it was a bread making machine
there was no design and this there was
just a bread making machine that
produced the bread but even if that were
the case the bread making machine
required prior design as did the recipe
for the dough that was put in it so this
is kind of analogous to what's going on
with a multiverse it only it doesn't
eliminate the problem of fine-tuning
it just push it pushes it back one
generation you know how'd the problem
with regard to the Big Bang so a lot of
folks have suggested that the Big Bang
is not actually the beginning so there
is no in the beginning there was prior
universe that sucked in on itself and
and then blew out again the basically
time is eternal and there was no
beginning to time necessarily well there
really aren't good cosmological models
that eliminate what's called the
singularity at the beginning temporally
the the standard Big Bang or the
inflationary cosmology model both
terminate in a definite beginning there
been a number of developments in
theoretical physics that have reinforced
that the singularity theorem of Hawking
Penrose and Ellis in 1968 and also the
theorem independently in physics the the
board with the lincoln theorem that
established a beginning but what people
have tried to do with theoretical
physicists have tried to do to get
around the theistic implications of
there being a beginning is formulating a
very abstract model of physics called
quantum cosmology that's that's where
the action is if you want to get around
the theistic argument for the existence
of god based on the beginning of the
universe and i'm writing about this -
it's really heady stuff but it's based
on an analogy to quantum physics and
some of your you know your your
listeners and viewers are very smart so
you they might know about the you know
the the weirdness of quantum physics
where particles act like waves and waves
act like particles so there's this
there's this thing called a wave
function that describes all the
different places that a particle might
be and then how it might collapse and
manifest one particular set of
attributes upon an observation and by
analogy some of the physicists have said
well maybe the universe came out of a
bigger wavefunction what they call a
universal wavefunction where there was
where there were all these different
possible universes that were existing in
what quantum physicists called
superposition sort of existing
simultaneously in an abstract
mathematical space of possibilities not
in not as physical reality and then
somehow someway all those different
possibilities collapsed and we got a
universe like ours okay now this is a
very bizarre thing for a number of
reasons one they've got a mathematical
equation generating a material universe
which is a very not materialistic
explanation of things it's almost as one
of the
proponents of this Alexander Vilenkin
noted he said math is an idea that
exists in mind so when we say that the
universe came out of a big universal
wavefunction equation are we really
saying that that the universe came out
of a pre-existing mind he raises that as
a rhetorical question at the end of one
of his books and then simply changes the
subject to finish the book the other
crazy thing is that to get that
mathematical equation that might explain
our universe you have to solve a prior
mathematical equation and you can't do
that without an input of information
which comes from the theoretical
physicist so like in those origin of
life experiments they're actually
modeling the need for a mind to generate
information and you get this weird
conclusion in the beginning was the word
so it's it's very strange the attempt to
get around the theistic implications at
the Big Bang have just have generated
other models which themselves have
implications that are very theistic okay
so in just one second I'm gonna ask you
a final question and ask about your own
religious background sure you come from
religiously yeah if you want to hear
Steven Myers answer you have to be a
daily wire subscriber to subscribe go
over to daily wire comm click Subscribe
you can hear the end of our conversation
there well book is Darwin's doubt the
author of Steven Mayer Steven thanks so
much for stopping by I really appreciate
it yeah we covered a lot thank you
[Music]
the venture Pierrot shows Sunday special
is produced by Jonathan hey executive
producer Jeremy boring associate
producer Mathis Glover edited by Donovan
Fowler audio is mixed by Dylan Kate's
hair and makeup is by Jess wah alvera
title graphics by Cynthia and Guillot
the Ben Shapiro shows Sunday special is
a daily wire production copyright daily
wire 20 19
[Music]
you